[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we know it these silver bullets tear up
this morning houses nothing live it's
smoke you know
[Music]
giving you a little preview here I like
I like the song I heard you know I heard
a little pop a little folks got a little
country feel to it is okay Miley you
know they said that this is and what
Mark Mark Ronson Mark Ronson he posted a
teaser on his Instagram a couple days
ago and he said that it is the
Heartbreak era is coming the Heartbreak
hair that's so interesting Mark Ronson
this is guy as a lot of people know he
is but I also feel like a lot of people
don't know I did it has a researcher
he's a big-time producer if you liked
and if you shook your butt at all -
uptown funk by Bruno Mars you were
dancing to Mark Ronson I mean that just
makes it this is not this is a hit
already so that's what this guy does is
he pairs up with super talented artists
and then just releases Smash Hits I'm
interested I want to see the rest of
this video I don't know I know that my
sigh oh here she cleaned out her old
Instagram to promote the video which is
pretty cool and then the first teaser
came out the 26 yeah there it is right I
mean the video is a little racy as we
you know we just saw we just saw that
but this is the last you know we haven't
heard from Miley since younger now which
was last sneeze there alright so this
was the first time we've heard from her
since younger now you know she just
turned 26 I feel like we've watched her
evolve in front of our eyes from the
Hannah Montana to dating Liam and then
her her bangers when she had a little
twerking little right and then now she's
back with Liam and she's thriving I just
feel like look this may be what what
really just solidifies Miley as a music
you know Julia well I well I'd say she's
been solidified for a while there's
nothing I like more than the evolution
of an artist and a lot of times if you
see people who started out a lot of
times on you know sort of the Disney
oriented shows one odd and at first it
seems to be a lot of pop and then as
they grow they sort of look what
happened and I just I just feel like
that that journey is so cool yeah it is
cool to watch definitely